hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to well an
overwhelming amount of viewers have made
it clear that there are two films that
put thus in cinematic shit mongering
that I must address Street Fighter and
Mortal Kombat and God can't tell you how
much I don't want review these suckers
if someone gave me a choice between
sitting through these movies again and
being crucified I'd say grab the nail
gun I hear there's a Lunger sale at Home
Depot's both of these movies are based
on the best fighting games that ever hit
the arcades Street Fighter 2 for its
speed and gameplay and Mortal Kombat for
its violence and gore but luckily all
that violence and gore have absolutely
no disturbing side effects on our decent
childhoods I'm sorry I have to do that
every 12 minutes now both of these
movies came out around the same time so
we got a double dose of disappointment
then summer but to keep it simple let's
review the first film that came out that
year Street Fighter so what's the main
problem with this piece of shit of a
movie 4 syllables jean-claude Van Damme
Van Damme is like the poor man's Chuck
Norris the guy you get if you think
Steven Seagal is too classy for your
movie he knows martial arts but he often
forgets that you need a personality in
order to be interesting anytime bigad
the only bigger insult to having a bad
actor and a bad film is having a good
actor in a bad film enter all Julia's
the villain and bison raúl juliá was one
of the most charismatic actors who ever
lived and was taken from us a million
times too early in fact it was rumoured
that role Julia did this as his last
film because it was something his
children really wanted him to do well
thank you you little brats he lived long
enough just to see the destruction of
his entire career
top notch warning this is clearly for
satirical purposes we're all Julia kicks
ass I'm sure his family kicks ass
you've lost your balls so what's the
story you're probably wondering well
ironically it involves absolutely no
street fighting whatsoever Van Damme
plays a war hero named guile who's out
to stop the evil
m.bison from you guessed it taking over
the world of course on top of his
fearsome army bison also has hostages
that is holding ransom for twenty
billion dollars guile being the fearless
leader has this
Oh can he do that on TV after that we
get a bad action sequence followed by
another bad action sequence followed by
oh hey look they're actually talking
here okay this is the scene where they
discuss their strategy - oh wait no no
sorry this is just about a bad action
sequence gals accompanied by three other
fighters chun-li Balrog and Hanten they
represent some sort of journalistic
secret agent fighting squad who are also
out to take on and bison now that's just
violating nonpartisan reporting these
three obviously have a very difficult
task ahead of them not taking out M
Bisons fearsome army but trying to
figure out what the hell their fearless
leader is saying call it a wake-up code
awaken car what's a wake-up call if I'm
not up side in 15 minutes
what and destruct his defenses huh if
Stiga Drance gets to bison who seriously
even the actors in the movie look at him
like they have no idea what he's saying
some moron just gave me hate to admit it
I think I might actually be missing
Schwarzenegger get the hostages out keep
the hostages out things start looking up
when it appears that guile has been shot
and murdered in the middle of a violent
shootout hey alright this movie's
finally starting to get good it turns
out that guile is still alive and this
death scene was just an attempt to fool
the enemy even though they spot him on a
speedboat just a few moments later which
makes this scene entirely pointless by
the way I love Geils army fatigue of
blue camouflage that will really come in
handy if they're ever fighting in the
sky or underwater the rest of the story
is kind of hard to keep track of
considering how there's so many damn
characters most adaptations have the
problem with leaving a character - out
but not street fighter no they have the
courtesy of giving us every single damn
annoying character these games ever
produced
like guile and bison chili Honda Zagat
Bell Rock Enron kami Zangief DJ Vega
Dawson T Hawk Blanca sneezy dopey grumpy
dancer Prancer comet Cupid cubby Tommy
pinky brain John Ringo cummerbund
it's nightmare everyone in the world is
here it's like a street fighter
Christmas okay I'm gonna do you a favor
and show you the only funny scene in
this entire movie it's one the villains
are watching a TV screen showing a truck
of explosives riding out of control only
to find that the truck is actually
heading right towards there quick trace
the child okay that's kind of funny but
trust me it's not worth it to watch
painful scenes like this one where the
most Dario typically smug British man
tells guille that they're giving in to M
Bisons demands deliver these
instructions to your troops then
consider yourself relieved of your
command we think we can deal with
general bison now if you excuse me I'm
off to burn down an orphanage and puppy
farm then guile delivers a speech that
even george w would find epically
ridiculous our superior say the war is
cancelled we can all go home oh god I
don't know how much more of this movie I
could take my son is getting paid up for
his crimes and our friends will have
died here but we can all go home yes yes
yes very tragic I got things to do sons
meanwhile ideals like peace freedom and
justice they get packed up but we can
all go home well we would if you would
stop yapping your trap well I'm not
going home no no don't do this to me
baby
you said I could go home I'm gonna get
on my board and I'm going to kick that
son of a bitch bison Sask heart of a
boat now who wants to go home and who
wants to go with me
one supply valve the billions going on
here involves Geils friend Blanca who's
transformed into a mix between the Hulk
and one of those cavemen you see from
the Geico commercials they're joking
this is done by a scientist named Olson
who is just a dead ringer for the
dhalsim in the videogame can you tell
the difference
hi sure can't actually one the strangest
parts of the movie involves his
appearance the last time we see him he
looks like this and then the next time
we see him he looks like this what the
hell happened one minute he looks like a
scientist the next he looks like the
bald guy from 300 and the movie never
tells us why did he just bloom into a
yogi Indian warrior was he on his way to
a Queequeg Hostin party at me it makes
no sense why do an onslaught of bad
lines and lame action scenes we finally
get to the showdown between Guilin and
bison granted Bisons army is totally
outnumbered and all they have to do is
shoot him in order to end this stupid
war but nope Kyle wants to risk
thousands of lives so he can show off
his cool hand-to-hand combat boos okay a
30 year old heavyweight takes on a 50
year old dictator gee I wonder who's
gonna win what a shock
at some point bison regenerates himself
as able to levitate throughout the room
so he flies up into the air and hits
Kyle's straight on and then after that
he flies up into the air and hits Kyle
straight on but then he has the
brilliant strategy of flying up in the
air and hitting guile straight on I
think finally the 12th time he does this
guy'll gets an idea maybe he should hit
him
you're off air hey I think probably the
strangest scene and trust me that's
saying a lot comes at the very end when
guile tries to rescue Blanca and dhalsim
Blanca says he can't face the world
looking how he does so dhalsim decides
to look after him in the comfort and
safety of a burning building I mean what
made them think that would be okay there
I'll even at one point says this whole
place is gonna go on it's a fixer-upper
but you can't beat that rent gee I
wonder how the armies feel knowing that
Geils best friend and an innocent
scientist were lost in that explosion I
guess they're taking it pretty well
horrible movie sucks ass next bill